[Musik]
>> SALLY: Hallo!
Herzlich willkommen zu Sallys Welt!
In meinem heutigen Video gibt es gleich vier Rezepte.
Ich mache nämlich Food-Geschenke aus der Küche,
also essbare Geschenke,
die ihr gerade jetzt zur Weihnachtszeit
natürlich wunderbar verschenken könnt.
Und es sind auch Geschenke, die man einfach machen kann,
mit wenig Zeitaufwand direkt eine große Menge.
Natürlich sind auch Pralinen oder Plätzchen dafür geeignet.
Aber heute gibt es Schokomandeln.
Die kennt ihr vielleicht auch.
Die gibt es ja oft auf Weihnachtsmärkten zu kaufen.
Ich weiß noch, der Volkan hat mir mal
welche aus Belgien mitgebracht mit belgischer Schokolade.
Und ich mag die Schokomandeln mit Kakao ganz gerne,
mit richtig dunklem Kakao, dunkler Schokolade.
Aber es gibt da natürlich
verschiedene Geschmacksrichtungen.
Geschmacksrichtungen, die ich allerdings
noch nie gesehen habe und noch nie angetroffen habe,
habe ich jetzt heute hier für euch zusammengestellt.
Ich mache jetzt nämlich Kakao-Zimt-Mandeln.
Dafür verwende ich natürlich ganze Mandeln.
Hier habe ich die Zartbitterschokolade,
etwas Vanilleextrakt,
Puderzucker,
Kakaopulver, was ungesüßt ist,
und etwas Zimt.
Dann gibt es Ruby-Himbeer-Mandeln.
Dafür nehme ich ganze Mandeln,
Ruby-Schokolade,
Himbeeren
– die sind gefriergetrocknet, das ist ganz wichtig –
und etwas Puderzucker.
Die goldenen Tonka-Mandeln bestehen aus
Mandeln,
Kakaopulver,
Vollmilchschokolade,
Tonka Wonka oder Tonkabohne, die gerieben wird,
und etwas Goldpuder.
Die vierte Sorte sind die Weiße-Schokolade-Kokos-Mandeln.
Dafür nehme ich die ganzen Mandeln,
Puderzucker,
Kokosflocken,
weiße Schokolade
und Vanilleextrakt.
Die genauen Mengenangaben zu allen vier Rezepten
findet er natürlich in meinem Blog oder in meiner App.
Und was ich jetzt hier gemacht habe:
Ich habe die Mandeln jetzt bereits aufgeteilt.
Denn ich mache jetzt vier Sorten
und mache jetzt nicht von jedem fünf Kilo,
sondern eben eine kleine Menge.
Ich habe die Mandeln jetzt hier in den Schälchen bereits.
So könnt ihr auch, wenn ihr wirklich alle 4 Sorten machen wollt,
supergut vorarbeiten.
Ich habe sie hier in Emailleschälchen gegeben.
Ihr nehmt einfach eine backfeste,
also eine backofenfeste Form.
Und die werden jetzt ganz kurz erwärmt.
Die Mandeln sollen jetzt nämlich zum einen
geröstet werden im Backofen,
damit sie eben einen schönen Geschmack haben.
Aber ich nutze auch direkt diese Wärme.
Denn ich habe in ganz vielen Rezepten gesehen,
dass Schokolade geschmolzen wird über dem Wasserbad.
Und ich zeige euch heute eine Methode,
die wirklich supereinfach ist,
wo ihr einfach die Backofenwärme nutzen könnt.
Also kommen die jetzt hier in den Backofen
bei 160°C Heißluft.
Dann könnt ihr auch wirklich ganz viele auf einmal machen.
Die sind jetzt auch schon perfekt vorbereitet.
Und jetzt nehme ich hier direkt die erste Menge.
Natürlich aufpassen, weil sie sehr heiß ist.
Und die anderen lasse ich jetzt solange im Backofen.
Da bleiben sie schön warm.
Was ich jetzt hier mache:
Ich gebe die Schokolade hier dazu.
Und durch die Wärme der Mandeln
schmilzt jetzt die Schokolade.
[Musik]
Jetzt kann ich hier noch direkt Vanilleextrakt zufügen
und den Puderzucker.
Wenn ihr sagt, euch reicht die Süße der Schokolade,
braucht ihr keinen Puderzucker.
Dann sind sie aber recht herb,
weil es wirklich eine sehr dunkle Zartbitterschokolade ist.
Wie gesagt, ich nehme da jetzt ein bisschen Zucker dazu.
Und jetzt einfach so ein bisschen rühren,
bis die Schokolade auch wieder leicht abkühlt.
Also die Mandeln sollen jetzt einfach komplett ummantelt sein.
Man sieht jetzt auch:
Durch die Zugabe des Puderzuckers
wird die Konsistenz so ein bisschen schon fester.
Ich glaube,
ja, mittlerweile geht das ganz gut.
Die Mandeln sind jetzt ummantelt,
nicht ummandelt.
Egal.
So. Dann nehme ich jetzt ein Gefäß,
was ich verschließen kann,
verrühre jetzt hier den Kakao mit dem Zimt.
Es ist halt auch echt cool, weil man wirklich
recht wenig Arbeit hat für viel
Produkt, was man am Ende eben rausbekommt.
Das kommt jetzt hier rein.
Und jetzt verschließen und schütteln.
Shake, shake, shake,
shake, shake, shake!
Shake the almonds!
Und dann mal reingucken.
Wenn ein paar aneinander kleben,
so wie hier,
kurz voneinander befreien.
Manchmal schafft es nämlich
– also ich kann halt nicht so kräftig schütteln.
Vielleicht schafft es der Josh besser,
weil er etwas stärker ist als ich.
Wir können es gleich testen.
Wir machen den Schütteltest.
Und weiter schütteln!
Und wenn sie dann alle ummantelt sind,
könnt ihr sie umfüllen.
Jetzt lasse ich die hier abkühlen
und werde sie später noch mal,
wenn sie wirklich schön abgekühlt sind,
noch mal mit Kakao bestäuben.
Und so ist Version eins schon fertig.
[Musik]
Für die Ruby-Himbeer-Version nehme ich,
wie gesagt, gefriergetrocknete Himbeeren.
Die sind einfach trocken.
Und es geht halt auch nur mit gefriergetrockneten,
also gefrorene oder frische Himbeeren gehen nicht.
Das muss ja gleich pulverisiert werden.
Es gibt aber auch schon Pulver, was man kaufen kann.
Dann habe ich hier den Puderzucker.
Die beiden Zutaten werden jetzt miteinander vermixt.
So sieht das dann aus.
Diese Masse kommt jetzt wieder hier rein.
Dann hier wieder die Schokolade
mit den Mandeln verschmelzen.
[Musik]
Und auch hier jetzt wieder, sobald die Schokolade anfängt,
wieder etwas abzukühlen und fester zu werden,
einfach in dieser Himbeermischung schütteln.
Und als Nächstes werde ich auch direkt
die nächste Sorte vorbereiten,
nämlich die Vollmilch mit Gold,
und werde da auch schon mal die Schokolade
praktisch in den Mandeln schmelzen.
Samira, möchtest du mir helfen?
>> SAMIRA: Okay.
>> SALLY: Guck mal. Du darfst jetzt
einfach die Schüssel nehmen und schütteln.
Nur nicht aus der Hand fallen lassen, aber so,
>> SAMIRA: Okay.
>> SALLY: dass die schön ummantelt werden.
Und gerade bei der Ruby-Schokolade, muss ich sagen,
passt Himbeere echt gut.
Denn Ruby-Schokolade
ist ja so die vierte Schokoladensorte,
also neben Zartbitter, weiß und Vollmilch,
und die schmeckt von sich aus schon fruchtig.
>> SAMIRA: Ja.
>> SALLY: Und das ist so richtig lecker.
[Musik]
Für die Vollmilchvariante habe ich jetzt hier
Kakao,
Gold
und, was ich nicht vergessen darf,
Tonka Wonka mit in die Mandeln.
Das Goldpulver könnt ihr auch am Ende drüber geben.
Also ihr könnt es auch jetzt zuerst mal in Kakao wälzen
und dann mit Gold bepudern.
Dann verliert sich es auch nicht.
[Musik]
Lieber am Ende Gold drauf.
Yes!
Und jetzt noch Variante vier.
[Musik]
Meine Assistentin ist jetzt
die Assistentin von Josh.
Sie ist jetzt hinter der Kamera.
Kamerakind Samira!
Super Arbeit, Samira!
>> SAMIRA: Ja.
>> SALLY: Ich gebe jetzt hier bei der letzten Sorte
noch die weiße Schokolade dazu
und werde jetzt hier gleich Puderzucker
und Kokosraspeln auch zerkleinern,
also die Kokosraspeln eher zerkleinern mit dem Puderzucker.
Hier kommt noch ein bisschen Vanille rein.
Und ich kann dann das Ganze eben genauso zubereiten.
[Musik]
Ich weiß gar nicht, welche ich probieren soll.
Also ich habe es ja letztes Mal schon probiert.
Ich hab die schon mal gemacht.
Ich muss dazu sagen, ich hab eigentlich gedacht,
dass mir Kamerakind Samira bei der Entscheidung hilft.
Aber es ist okay.
Also
diese Schokomandeln, die mit Kakao,
sind schon immer richtig gut.
Die hier, die finde ich so genial mit Himbeeren,
weil die Ruby-Schokolade eben
so ein bisschen fruchtig schmeckt
und die Himbeeren sind ja eher säuerlich.
Und das passt einfach so perfekt
mit diesem Knack der Mandel,
dann diese süße Schokolade
und dann die säuerlichen Himbeeren.
Mmh!
Ist schon ein sehr großer Favorit von mir, muss ich sagen.
Hier habe ich ja die Version Tonka.
Die, finde ich, sehen halt auch richtig edel aus.
Ist leider auch sehr gut.
Und dann
– ich hätte es nicht gedacht,
weil ich nicht so der Weiße-Schokoladen-Fan bin,
aber in Verbindung mit Kokos
ist die Version leider auch sehr gut.
Mmh!
>> SAMIRA: Wieso leider?
>> SALLY: Weil ich dann leider alle esse.
Und der Vollständigkeit halber
probiere ich natürlich noch die für euch.
Mmh!
Also ich habe vier Favoriten.
Alle vier.
Ich muss halt echt sagen,
ich könnte euch jetzt nicht sagen,
macht die eine oder die andere Version,
sondern probiert einfach alle aus,
direkt in großer Menge.
Die halten sich ja auch eine Weile.
Und man kann sie wirklich supertoll verschenken.
Und ich finde, es ist einfach was für jeden dabei.
Die dunklen hier sind mehr so ein bisschen herb,
ich denke, eher was für Menschen,
die viel dunkle Schokolade mögen.
Die hier sind eben für alle, die etwas fruchtig mögen.
Die hier sind einfach total aromatisch und lecker
durch die Tonkabohne.
Und die hier sind eben
für alle Kokos- und Weiße-Schokoladen-Fans.
Daher sucht euch gerne eure Lieblingssorte aus.
Probiert das Rezept gerne aus.
Verschenkt es an eure Nachbarn, an Freunde, Bekannte,
an die Familie.
Ich finde es einfach eine schöne Geste.
Und ja, im Prinzip findet ihr alle Rezepte
bei mir in der App und auf meinem Blog.
Und ich freue mich auf euer Feedback.
Vielleicht wandelt ihr auch noch was ab
und habt noch eine eigene Idee.
Dann schreibt sie auch gerne in die Kommentare.
Und dann wünsche ich euch schon mal ganz viel Spaß dabei!
Vergesst nicht, die richtig hübsch zu verpacken
und dann zu verschenken.
Also bis zum nächsten Mal.
Tschüss!
[Musik]